thank you
[Music]
I don't really have a lot of information
on this one but this this video is
coming out hot in a lot of different
places so is it Andrew take on it but
let's all watch the video together and
then we can all just talk about it let's
talk about it
okay ready see
it matter to you you're going straight
to the top side there's [ __ ] kids
around here you can't place through the
[ __ ] stop sign yeah you think you
didn't stop [ __ ] jerk off
what's the whole point
yeah oh [ __ ]
oh
my
God
can you come in online what
yeah
Mom okay
work
why where the [ __ ] do you think you are
I'm telling you there's kids around here
[ __ ] you don't pull the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're coming at me
myself
put your [ __ ] hands on your head hey
Mom hey Mom
I'm thanking myself you coming out yeah
you [ __ ] chased me in the parking lot
you don't live here oh this could have
been avoided
he got offended
he pulled out a knife
he's like I'll shove this up your ass
[ __ ] step back no I'm not stepping down
he pulled the [ __ ] knife on me why he
pulled a knife on me cause he's psycho
and having a [ __ ] episode get the I
want to see your badge right [ __ ]
here wow he's a cop cover cop tell him
my husband's a cop please hold on tell
him to hurries tell them to hurry
step back I like that
get back away from me step back away
from me yeah jail step down away from me
right now
he starts [ __ ] having a roadway
density with me what happened where
the stop sign oh yeah so it's cursing
your screen again wait what happened
what did you do so I turned around and I
asked him what his problem was
and he comes in here like a psycho you
know we had we had we had a lot of
deaths and very bad we're having a very
bad a lot of deaths
yeah he's nice he cares on that when he
pulled it out
were you threatening him with a gun good
enough I appreciate the non-shaky camera
yeah he has him she's good and that's
what
videos that went over a minute I'm so
[ __ ] confused as to what happened
because it seemed like uh in the
beginning the guy that dropped the
n-bomb he was saying uh like that guy
was the guy that was speeding and
running through red lights yeah so he
basically said like this this guy ran
like a stop sign or something like that
um and then so the video starts off with
the two of them just yelling at each
other that the balder guy who ends up
pulling out a knife is like you want
there's [ __ ] kids here blah blah this
guy's like why don't you mind your own
[ __ ] business are you a cop and he's
like no I'm not a cop about blah blah
right and then this guy uh the the
undercover cop or the osterdy cop it
says undercover here but let's just say
the undercover cop she's just kind of
like all right like you know you need to
mind your own business and then the dude
is like you know I you know mind your
own [ __ ] business but [ __ ] you you
guys like don't talk to me like that
I'll talk to you all at one man I got
something right here shove it up your
ass yeah that was a good line that's it
and that's a threat that's where it
changes yeah that's where it changes
let's turn into a different thing and
then he and then that's when that guy
pulls out a knife and starts walking
towards the cop
and that's when the gun comes left yeah
pulls out the gun and then that's when
that whole situation I'm surprised he
didn't shoot him down I thought that was
gonna happen yeah I was like nervous
because I didn't see the knife dude like
my I don't have good criminal eyes you
know like I think that guy should get
his badge taken away yeah man because he
kind of I don't know I feel like that
could have easily been avoided yeah
everyone both part so like 100
as quickly as possible your goal is to
always de-escalate especially if you're
a cop man and he's escalating yeah he's
just adding to the chat room
de-escalating he's following this guy in
this parking lot right and he's a cop so
he should kind of already know better
like hey dude yeah some guy flipped you
off and said stop like okay whatever you
let those [ __ ] yeah it doesn't matter
that means you're looking for trouble
kind of in a weird way hit him with a
car because that guy's car looked
damaged no it wasn't it wasn't anything
of their Collision it's just he ran a
stop
from a road rage incident a gun got
pulled now yeah first the knife and then
the gun yeah yeah yeah so yeah I think
he's like I was yelling at was he also
driving or was he just yelling at him to
drive safer yeah she said that he pulled
along so he started cussing him out uh
for not stopping at the stop sign in his
neighborhood yes he's been like a
neighborhood hero yeah he's being
exactly yeah they're both [ __ ] I
mean I mean yeah he doesn't need to pull
out a knife but damn dude what the [ __ ]
was that there you know especially for
your car is undercover so he's like I
need to act like a person would yeah
he's probably off duty because he's with
his wife
she is with his wife he's probably you
know what it looks like it looks like a
guy that got his ego hurt and now he
needs to pull out his gun yeah and like
control the situation he they're
supposed to be held to a higher standard
right and the higher standard is you
don't let anybody talking crap piss you
off like you you fight with your words
and then you subdue them and then if you
have to then you do physical harm that's
like that's like security and
self-defense 101. our old um karate
Sensei like
everyone says karate doesn't [ __ ]
work but I'll tell you it's worked
multiple times for him all right have
they seen Kobe Kai yeah well like he was
hanging out at the bar I think out in
Downey or one of these cities right now
yeah and then and then and then um you
know this guy at the bar picks a fight
with the guy and then uh you know he he
picks a fight with our Sensei and he's
like man I don't want to [ __ ] fight
whatever and then so they go to the
parking lot and he's like walk into his
car he gets confronted again and so he's
like [ __ ] it and they just throw down
and mind you he's like at this time he's
like mid-40s you know like like five
five Japanese guy right and then like he
[ __ ] gets them down
the dude gets back up pulls out his
badge after he got beat up he gets his
ass beat
[ __ ] no you're gonna get it yeah
pulls out his badge arrests him book
some takes him down to the station
abuses his [ __ ] power but get this
there's a [ __ ] awesome end to the
story
my Sensei goes around and says I'm suing
this [ __ ] City he turns around
takes him to court wins the case comes
out with money comes out with nice
things but I don't know if the cop ever
[ __ ] maybe a suspension yeah pay
leave right leave probably yeah he's
just a like he just abused his power
dude if you're gonna pull out the badge
it needs to be like early you know you
can't like when it's in your favor all
of a sudden yeah there's a trump card
like if he's gonna be if he's like okay
I need to use my badge to control the
situation it needs to be like right away
Hey sir I'm just dishing no I'm a police
officer um we can lower our voices like
you know de-escalate immediately versus
you get your ass kicked and then pull it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and then it's like I'm a
cop actually it's like what the [ __ ]
dude come on man yeah I thought you won
the case that's nice plus like it's for
sure got to be like off duty right if
he's with his wife and [ __ ] like that
you know which is like totally different
on the floor that's a [ __ ] ego move
dude yeah
like he doesn't have to make him get on
the floor if I hear him say drop your
weapon or anything like that he just
said get on the ground whatever whatever
because all the whole time I was like
dude this guy's pulling out a gun
because his feelings got hurt like like
up until the point where like he pulls
out the knife but then again if a guy
pulled a knife out it does make sense
he's in Just Cause to pull his gun out
but the point is like you shouldn't even
got there yeah the way it gets to like
are you are you a cop like you know what
I mean it's like funny that's funny
that's funny though it's reverse
psychology why would you do that you
have to tell me if you are
you know it's illegal because what would
have happened if he if he if he said
that and he goes yeah I'm a cop and he
goes well I am tuned
I'm telling you [ __ ]
outside these kids around here
I'm minding my business I'm minding my
business you don't mind your [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] talk to me like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you yeah I got something for you
I'll shake it right up your
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah come on
come on oh right there he also told him
to come here he said yeah okay
and he's walking towards them you know
because he was walking backwards with a
knife he brought a knife to a gunfight
though
he challenged him he [ __ ] was like oh
yeah
I mean that guy did pull out a knife and
start walking at the guy though so he
was walking back he pulled out the knife
going backwards and goes come here and
then he goes all right then what do you
want because he flipped them off yeah so
he said okay I'll pull out a challenge
you know he did escalate the situation
because no matter what the guy shouldn't
have never pulled out the knife that
that is justify for a gun to come out
yeah but at the end of the day it was It
was kind of it was kind of enticed
especially a no like a [ __ ] who knows he
himself is a cop knows he has a gun he
knows he has a badge yeah why are you
[ __ ] you know why are you [ __ ]
trying to big dick your way into
situations like de-escalate make him
pull the knife
he challenged him and was like because
there was a bunch of up different parts
where he was like well [ __ ] you all
right Dan like [ __ ] you and that's when
it stops like they're they're about to
separate and then he's like I got
something for your ass he's like oh yeah
let me see what it is you want to put
something in my ass you'd show me and
he's like okay and he's like oh well I
got something for you too they call me
sunny the uncuttable what do you got and
maybe this cop [ __ ] did run the stop
sign we don't know yeah yeah I probably
did you know the cop had like 30 outs
for sure and he didn't choose any of
them he just kept escalating honey call
the cops
can can you call the cops I gotta get
the video
I can't do both that really is like an
obnoxiously annoying way to tell someone
hey man there's kids around so just like
make sure like you're asking for some
dumb [ __ ] to happen man yeah he's not
he's nuts and even the people drive off
yeah I understand the cause but that
ain't how you get the message across for
anybody like No One's Gonna If he if
that guy didn't have a gun on him do you
think he would have ever pulled into
that lot and like approached him to talk
[ __ ] to him right that's that's the
[ __ ] question like yeah how does he
even get there think about that a little
bit like oh as soon as that gun came out
whoa whoa whoa
I imagine myself I just start running
I'm like that might make him want to
just shoot me in the back too yeah yeah
probably you see a gun you don't know
what's going to happen yeah I just
zigzag and Sprint well you you know they
have harsher gun laws in New Jersey than
la
so like it's pretty strict out there so
like well ours is you could call it the
gonna get released tomorrow
but you have to prove you were trying to
rob someone
when you're alone biting Citizen though
you get the maximum but if you're
robbing 7-Eleven they'll let you out the
next day that's a good deal and they
can't you get late check out tomorrow
but over there you're too late night
lunches I heard lunch here is amazing
but I wonder if the criminals out there
just don't suspect citizens to have guns
because of that because it's such a like
you know no one has guns out there and
that's why the when you see people
shooting back that's a very small
percentage right because most of the
time they're getting away with it and
the little times they don't get away
with it is when you see it on the
internet yeah that's true so that's why
they're still running in the middle of
broad daylight trying to rob hurt people
because they're getting away with this
crazy what's happening in L.A dude again
now they're now they're mob stealing
freaking 7-Elevens and liquor stores in
L.A in La a confrontation we even have
that much dialogue
you probably get that's true two
sentences in and then one of them shot
that's too much talking yeah it's a lot
of barking yeah I saw a video the other
day it was so heartwarming it was uh two
guys at the road rage and uh
heartwarming why they start kissing
sorry yeah it was like oh this is how it
should be the middle of the freeway they
get out right and they start fighting in
the middle of the freeway and then one
dude gets dropped boom and then he gets
up he's like all right uh F this I'm out
of here they fought one guy got beat up
they went their separate ways they
settled it and then traffic freaking did
he help him up yeah yeah that's what he
like knocks them down they settled their
beef went on with their life you can't
get out your system yep nobody's honking
their horn like everyone's like all
right little finish from then on they
drove perfectly yeah exactly they both
except the guy was knocked out was
[ __ ] bumping everybody
holy he was getting shot at
[Music]